لحظه فرح في ايام تراجيديا زلزال مدمر في
سوريا سعاده الطفل وفرق الانقاذ ظرفيه
[تصفيق]
يا عمري
فالماسات طويله وكبيره بكل تفاصيلها
المؤلمه لا تملك فرق الانقاذ ما يكفي من
المعدات لاخراج الناشئين وانتشال الجثث
ورفع الانقاض حتى الباب ما شاء الله ما
شاء الله في بعض المناطق المتضرره يتولى
المواطنون بايديهم عمليه البحث عن ذويهم
وشيرانهم تتاخر المساعدات الانسانيه
الدوليه المطلوبه لاسباب سياسيه معقده وفي
كل تاخير يعاجل الموت من استعصى انقاذهم
سواء تحت الركام او في المستشفيات الفقيره
اصلا بسبب ظروف الحرب
الله يرحمه يودعهم فردا فردا مصابه جلل في
يوم واحد سيدفن خمسه وعشرين من عائلته
الصغيره والكبيره بينهم ابنته واحفاده
ربنا من الحرب
على اساس
ولاولادنا والاخير
سبحان الله القدر لوين
ملايين السوريين نزحوا او لجاوا منذ 2011
هربا من القصف والاشتباكات في مناطق
التماس وكثير منهم استقروا في المدن
التركيه التي دمرها الزلزال القاتل خاصه
في غازي عنتاب وانطاكيا دخل وطنهم او
خارجه الاف منهم اليوم يبتون في الشارع في
طقس بارد لا يرحم ماما مصيرهم واي مكان
سيؤويهم بعد الان تدهور البنى التحتيه
وغياب الامكانيات يعقد عمليات الانقاذ
المستمره في عتمه الليل ودون اضاءه كافيه
وبلا ادوات حفر متطوره لا يتوقف المسعفون
عن العمل يحدوهم دائما الامل في العثور
على ناجين
حدثت بعض المعجزات منذ كابوس فجر الاثنين
لكنها ضوء خافت وسط صوره مظلمه باعداد
القتلى المرتفعه يوما بعد يوم وبظروف
انتشال الجثث وشبه حياه الناجين جسديا من
الموت الصور من السماء مرعبه وعلى الارض
لكلمه تصف بدقه المصيبه التي حلت
بالسوريين الزلزال سوى بالارض بيوتا
يسكنها ما بقي من صبر على المحن ومن
سوريين يتحملوا الكثير ولاكثر من عقد من
الزمن
البلد يستغيث اكثر من اي وقت مضى لنجدته
من كارثه طبيعيه لم تفرق بين سوريا واخر
ومنطقه واخرى ثمه وطن واحد ابنائه تحت
الركام منذ الاثنين المفجع